this
you guys paid for all this so
seriously for every amazon customer out
there
and every amazon employee thank you from
the bottom of my heart very much
it's very appreciated
and uh you know now onto how it felt
oh my god
my expectations were high and they were
dramatically exceeded
the we were talking about this a little
bit
in the car ride on the way back and
i don't know the the zero g
piece may have been one of the biggest
surprises because
it felt so normal
it felt so like almost like we were as
humans evolved to be in that environment
which i know is impossible
but it felt so serene and peaceful and
the floating
it's actually much nicer than being in
full one gravity
um it's a very pleasurable experience
just from the sheer just the way it
feels the tactileness of it
that it you know the the most profound
piece of it for me was looking out at
the earth
and looking at the earth's atmosphere
every astronaut
everybody who's been up into space they
say this that it changes them and they
look at it and they're kind of amazed
and
awe struck by the earth and its beauty
but also by its fragility
and i can vouch for that um when i look
out you know when we're sitting in this
room
when we're driving our cars and we're
moving around the planet
in our normal ways the atmosphere is so
gigantic
you know we're these tiny little things
and the planet the atmosphere is so big
but when you get up above it what you
see is it's actually incredibly thin
it's this tiny little fragile thing and
as we move about the planet we're
damaging it and you know so that is um
you know that's that that's a very
profound it's one thing to recognize
that intellectually
it's another thing to actually see with
your own eyes
how fragile it really is and that was
amazing
who wants to add oliver you want to tell
us how it was
our first paying customer you feel like
you got your money's worth sir
[Laughter]
no was so amazing to see it from above
and to move around like
yeah i totally agree it feels so natural
like
almost like we should be doing this and
i hope that we are
one of the first and let's hope that
many many more people can do this
because this experience you should share
with more and more people
it's so amazing and a special
congratulations to you on becoming the
youngest person
to have ever flown in thank you
you brought with you up there the next
generation of space explorers but
certainly
uh another flag up there the netherlands
to everybody out there the netherlands
there's the new dutch flying man there
you go
mark you should say that you told me in
the car about the g-forces i thought
that was really interesting
well i was uh i was surprised i mean
they had told us what
you know what g-forces would feel like
on the way up and
um you know again it's one of those
things that you hear about you
anticipate but
um you know you really feel them on the
way up it was incredibly exhilarating
and then
um you know on the way back down what i
had not anticipated so we hit five g's
briefly on the way back down um and
that's that's a lot of pressure and
unfortunately
during the um the
status check for each at each astronaut
by the time they got to astronaut demo
which was the name i was flying under
we were at five g's and so they were
like astronaut demo how you doing
okay i had a hard time had a hard time
responding but uh
i'm not sure what that video footage
will look like probably not very pretty
by the way it was so exciting if you
haven't figured it out yet
uh well wally might be the oldest person
ever in space and oliver the youngest
person
ever in space my brother is the funniest
person ever in space
uh for sure i have before i want to do a
couple of
more things before we maybe go to next
questions which is
i want to recognize two people who here
in the audience
we are honored today to have
alan shepard's daughters laura and julie
could you stand up just briefly so we
could say
and of course uh alan shepard was a
apollo moonwalker and has a gigantic
list of accomplishments but for our
purposes today
uh the thing that is most interesting
about alan shepard
is that he is the namesake for this
vehicle news shepard
and that is because the pro the mission
profile that we did today
is very similar to the one that allen
flew when he became the first american
in space
i guess 60ish years ago so that is
uh we're very honored to have you guys
here and thank you for joining us
it's incredible i i got some pictures
with them backstage and
i know those are getting blown up big
thank you uh
so and then i have a couple things to
show let's can we start you want to talk
about the
couple of things we flew like the go
ahead oh we did
um so we had the opportunity to bring
with us uh was actually on loan from
the explorers club we were able to fly
with a piece of canvas
from the right flyer um so the the plane
that the wright brothers flew
um we brought a piece of that canvas
with us which was
really powerful as well as a bronze uh
medallion uh that was made from
uh the first uh hot air balloon flight
um in 1783 which was the first time
um man ever uh you know left the earth
in controlled flight so we're very
thrilled to be able to bring both of
those along with us
um and we brought those precious objects
back yes we did
and the explorers club will be pleased
they're very happy about that and we
have um one more thing which i would
actually just like to show you
if you could who has the goggles could
you please bring them up to me
yeah would you hold that this is
incredible so
all right wouldn't you stand still this
we also flew these are amelia earhart's
goggles the ones she flew across the
atlantic with
solo and you can see she put tape over
them
to kind of make have less light come in
because it was just so bright all the
day and she was flying for so long
and they're just i i like to think
that if amelia were here she'd be very
very
and i just can't i can't resist doing
this
so thank you amelia wherever you are we
hope you're
watching all of this
and while on that note wally
uh oh i'm sorry oh please thank you
lauren just reminded me i have one more
thing
which is and christina i might need your
help on this but
mom could you come up for a second
where's my mom
okay you don't have to come up i can
come to you i have
i wore this
i wore this necklace i wore this
necklace and it is a
uh lords and feather and i wore it up
into space
and now it's for you
[Applause]
okay and now wally last but not least
amelia earhart what a what a lovely uh
transition
an aviation icon and now an aerospace a
space icon what was it like
i can't tell you i had such a good
instructor he told us through
everything that we were gonna do so when
i went up this morning
the noise wasn't quite as bad and we
went
right on up and i saw darkness i thought
i was gonna see the world but we were
quite high enough and i felt great
it it i felt like i was just laying down
i was just laying down
and i was going into space
and i want to thank you sweetheart
because you
made it possible for me i've been
waiting a long time
to finally get it up there and i've done
a lot of astronaut training
through the world russia america
and i could always beat the guys on what
they were doing because i was always
stronger and i've always done everything
on my own and
i didn't do dolls i did outside stuff
and i flew airplane that was 19 000 some
hours
i loved it and i loved being here with
all of you
and your family and
the the four of us we had a great time
it was it was wonderful i want to go
again
fast
[Laughter]
and then when i got off the ship they
gave me the tail end
of one of the balloons and i'm going to
cherish that forever
by the way we can confirm that wally
once again in training
outperformed the men on the mission 100
i was going to say she beat all the the
three boys
up to the top of the crew access hour
everybody saw that there's video footage
indeed darling you did you did well so
wally funk now the world's uh oldest
astronaut who have ever gone to space
and
perhaps the first founding member of our
blue origin uh
frequent flyer program
sounds like she's ready for it when i do
lectures or wherever i am around
the world in the united states i'm only
45.
[Music]
you're being generous i keep saying
everybody every time somebody says oh
she's 82. i think there's a typo sure
you're 28 wally we know this
well now well thank you so much for for
giving us your impressions but
let's see it with our own eyes i'd like
to roll the tape of what it was like in
the crew cabinet
[Music]
look oliver
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
look at the blackness of space
[Music]
oh yeah
oh
this is incredible oh i love it
i love it oh wow
yeah it's a little different
i could not oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was a good catch
wally was it everything you expected and
more you've been waiting as you said six
years to experience this i i loved every
minute of it i just wish it a little
longer because i have been
in space before i'm not in space with up
in that area and
could do a lot more rolls and twists and
so forth
but there was not quite enough room for
all four of us to do all those things
it was great i loved it i could hardly
wait to go again
amen next next stop for you is the moon
wally
any other impressions now having seen
the video of it
is it is it one of those things where
you just took it in
and it's hard to compare to video what
are other sensations that come from
having seen that right now felt way
cooler than it looked
well so after of course their their four
minutes of weightlessness the fun that
you had of course we got you buckled
back in
and you descended under those beautiful
three parachutes i think we've got
another video here of your descent back
to our beautiful
west texas valley why don't we roll that
right now
that moment felt pretty good i'm not
gonna lie that's true when you see the
three main shoots out
that's relaxing that was so easy it was
just incredible
whoa i didn't feel that
well that's because it's actually dust
kicked up by a cushion of air that makes
you only hit it about one mile an hour
it feels like if you were to stand up in
your chair just kind of plop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our family was happy to see us that's a
good sign
what was that moment like coming back
and seeing your your friends and your
family here you have supported them
or they have supported you that is your
dreams to get to this point
oliver your father is here joseph thank
you so much for being here
what was that like yeah well he was a
bit more emotional than i
would have thought like everyone on the
ground was way more emotional than we
were we were just having fun
it's so true yeah
yeah i think that our uh our family has
been extremely supportive through all of
this and i think that
um you know they're i know my wife was
an absolute rock
leading up to this um which made um you
know the adventure
much easier for me but i know that uh
when we came down it was sort of
uh time to let those emotions out a
little bit so uh it was it was great to
see everybody and yeah it was a little
more emotional than i had anticipated as
well
jeff yeah i mean um you know
for i wasn't that nervous but my family
was
somewhat anxious about this and uh
so it was it was so sweet
actually when to get hugged by them
after landing
especially my kids and lauren and my mom
and dad and
really all of you guys and you know we
have a bunch of close friends here too
and uh it just makes me realize how much
i love you
and how much i'm loved
and wally your friend mary is here yes i
am so happy she's here she knows what
i'm going through she's
been she was one of my flight students
and i've had many many or five three
thousand flight students and i don't
know if they're going to get to see this
or not
but i felt so charged i was not nervous
i was just normal normal person
going up into space and that's what i
wanted to feel nothing here
i can confirm that while i was never
nervous
[Laughter]
she was she was wondering what was
taking so long
[Laughter]
it's true we had a six minute hold on
the pad and while i was like are we
gonna go or not
what the hell we're burning daylight
let's go
[Laughter]
but then wally once we got you going we
got you going fast going over
mach 3 and it's this beautiful rocket
behind us here
our new shepard rocket that got the team
up to space
and by the way it also of course made
its uh it's landing back on the landing
pad why don't we take a look at that
that landing that we have here
whew
that was a bullseye absolutely bullseye
jeff a beautiful piece of engineering
that our team here at blue origin
has developed would you like to talk to
us a little bit a bit about
why we chose vertical takeoff vertical
landing
being powered by this be3 engine
because today is not the end right we're
going further with this technology no
that's a
a helpful question because um the fact
of the matter
is that the architecture and the
technology we have chosen
is complete overkill for our suborbital
tourism mission
um we have chosen the vertical landing
architecture
why do we do that because it scales it's
an architecture that can grow to very
large size
so we want to have we want to have
experience with architectures that can
grow
big to new glenn and one day to new
armstrong
so to have the idea that you want to
build big from the beginning
lets you choose an architecture because
the whole point of doing this is to get
practice
and other kinds of architectures don't
scale in the same way to large to very
large size vertical landing does
in fact you can think about it very
easily because
if you try to when you are landing a
rocket vertically
you are solving what's called the
inverted pendulum problem and you are
balancing
a broomstick on the tip of your finger
and you can
balance a broomstick on the tip of your
finger you know what you cannot balance
on the tip of your finger
a pencil so basically the smaller
the object the harder it is to balance
as the object gets bigger and bigger and
bigger it gets easier and easier and
easier to balance
it's very simple because this has more
more more momentum
so it's easier to get under it so that
architecture skills that's why we chose
it
and then the second thing that is a very
puzzling architecture choice for most
people who know a lot about rockets
you would never choose liquid hydrogen
for a suborbital tourism mission
it's completely unnecessary it's the
most powerful
highest performing rocket fuel in the
world
and there are two reasons we chose it
the first is
again practice we chose that propellant
because it's the it is what you see
behind me
is basically the second stage of new
glenn
and so every time we fly this tourism
mission we're practicing flying the
second stage of new glenn
and that's where you really do want
hydrogen on the second stage of
a of a vehicle that is designed not only
to go into low earth orbit but to
bodies outside of earth orbit and then
the other reason we chose it is because
it is the most environmentally benign
propellant
you can choose the when you burn
hydrogen and oxygen
you get h2o h2o is water
and it's so that is another thing for a
tourism mission that was really
important to us
as well so uh that's why we chose this
architecture you see behind me
and um the engineering team did an
incredible job
they also really built two vehicles uh
what you see
is not really a vehicle because i can
assure you the escape system
was at least as complicated hard to
design
and to test and demonstrate as the main
booster itself
so that was it's almost like building a
whole separate vehicle and i'm also
extremely happy we didn't test it today
thank you so much again congratulations
to you all with that i'm going to turn
it over to linda mills
head of communications here at blue
origin to start the press conference
thank you very much
woo let's give another round of applause
to our amazing
newly minted astronauts
all right i would like to give a thank
you to our journalists who
showed up at 2 30 this morning to get
set up i know it's been a long day for
all of you
i can't believe you guys are still
smiling thank you thank you
so we'll be able to take a few questions
and then we'll um
just pose for a few photos so rachel why
don't you start rachel with cnn
congratulations you guys on
your astronaut thank you rachel said in
the past that the work you're doing
is the most important of your career
you've recently sit down
as ceo amazon can you expect for you to
be more hands-on
yes so i'm going to split my time
between uh blue origin and the bezos
earth fund
the basal service fund is about climate
change and sustainability
and that is those two things and there's
going to be a third thing
and maybe a fourth thing but i don't
know what those are yet i'm not very
good at doing one
thing are you gonna be flying against
you i said hell yes
how fast can you refuel that thing let's
go all right next question
uh let's go uh reuters
so eric asked about the cadence and the
capabilities
okay we're going to fly
human missions twice more this year
and what we do in the following year i'm
not sure yet
we will we'll figure that out and what
the cadence will eventually be
we want the cadence to be very high and
one thing we've found out through the
auction process and what we've been
doing is private sales
we're approaching 100 million dollars in
private sales already
and the demand is very very high so
we're going to keep
after that because we really do want to
practice with this vehicle
so we're gonna have to build more more
booster uh
more boosters and to fly more frequently
and we're gonna be doing that and
working on all the operational things we
need to do all the things we learn what
practice does
is let you get better and we want to be
able right now you know
we have a mission life we think
sometimes somewhere between 25 and 100
flights
for one of these vehicles we like to
make that you know
closer to 100 than to 25 and then once
it's close to 100 will
push it past 100. that's how you get
operational usability you have to
remember
uh big things start small i told this
crew when we
when we got in today we were sitting
there on the pad waiting to lift off
um we had time to ourselves and and i
just said
guys if you if you if you're willing if
you let me invite you
when we get up there and aft you know
there's gonna be all kinds of adrenaline
all kinds of excitement all kind of
novel novelty
but take a minute take us take take
take a few seconds to look out and
calmly think about what we're doing it's
not only adventure it is adventure and
it is fun
but it's also important because what
we're doing
is the first step of something big and i
know what that feels like
i did it three decades ago almost three
decades ago
with amazon and we are
big things start small and you but you
can tell
you can tell when you're on to something
and this is important uh
we're going to build a road to space
so that our kids and their kids can
build the future
and we need to do that we need to do
that to solve the problems here on earth
this is not about escaping earth every
time i read an article about
people wanting to escape earth no no no
the whole point is
this is the most this is the only good
planet in this solar system
we've sent robotic probes to all of them
this is the only good one
i promise you we have to take care of it
and when you go into space and see how
fragile it is you'll want to take care
of it even more
and that's what this is about we have to
take and this is going to take decades
this is a big vision but big things
start small
and this is how it starts and we are
going to build an
infrastructure just like when i started
amazon i didn't have to build the postal
service
or royal mail or deutsche post there
were people
they were already gigantic worldwide
infrastructure to deliver packages
that infrastructure today is for space
just
way too expensive and it doesn't work
but if we can
practice with this suborbital tourism
mission and continue and build bigger
and bigger vehicles
timelines on new armstrong and and so on
i can't really give you because we don't
know um but what i can tell you
is we're going to keep working at those
things step by step
ferociously and i want to emphasize the
ferociously
all right we have time for one last
question
and tom costello with nbc
tom costello with nbc news
congratulations to all of you
jeff to follow up on that on that
question and your discussion there
how do you make this more reasonable
for everyday people who would like to
fly it's pretty steep right now
how do you bring the cost down so that
this can be more accessible
for everybody it's a great question how
do you bring the cost down over time
so it's more accessible to everyone
you've got to do it the same way we did
it with commercial airline travel
you know we are still we're not even
we're really almost in the barnstormer
phase
right so this is these are you know
biplanes
and they're flying into a farmer's field
and charging a small
pro a price to fly people around for a
few minutes in the air
that's what we're doing right now but
you know where that barnstorming phase
leads
to 787s and that's what we have to do
all right let's give a hand i'm afraid
that's all the time we have for
questions today these astronauts have
had a very long day
um so let's give another round of
applause for astronauts
and the job i think you had one more
thing guys i have one
i have one more thing i have a little
surprise for you
um i am announcing today
a new philanthropic initiative and
if you put the slide up so people can
see it
it is called the courage and civility
award
it recognizes leaders who aim high and
who pursue solutions with courage
who always do so with civility
well
let me tell you how i feel about this i
feel strongly enough actually wrote
something down
um we live in a world where
sometimes instead of disagreeing with
someone's ideas
we question their character or their
motives
and guess what after you do that
it's pretty damn hard to work with that
person
and really what we should always be
doing is questioning ideas
not the person ad hominem attacks have
been around a long time but they don't
work
and they've been amplified by social
media
we need unifiers and not vilifiers
we want people who argue hard and act
hard for what they truly believe
but they do that always with civility
and never ad hominem attacks and
unfortunately we live in a world
where this is too often not the case but
we do have role models
and this award do you have another slide
here to
go ahead
first i didn't tell you what the award
was yet i thought there was a slide for
that
here's what the award is you see who the
first recipient is
but let me tell you what the award is
the
courage and civility award is
a 100 million dollar award so that the
awardee the recipient
can give 100 million dollars to
the charities the nonprofits of their
choice
and these people these are people who
have
demonstrated courage by the way it's
easy to be courageous
but also mean try being courageous and
civil
try being courageous and a unifier
that's harder and way better
it makes the world better so the we have
two awardees today they'll each be
getting
100 million dollars to direct to the
charities
of their choices they see fit no
bureaucracy
no committees notice they just do what
they want they can give it all to their
own charity or they can share the wealth
it's up to them
and the first uh courage and civility
award
goes to van jones van come on up
thank you brother
um
sometimes dreams come true
sometimes dreams come true
and the headlines around the world
should be
anything's possible if you believe and
um
lauren and jeff don't do nothing small
man they don't do anything small
they just don't do it they dream big uh
they love big and they bet big
and you bet on me and i appreciate it
and i'm gonna tell you the only thing i
worry about when you say courage
i haven't always been courageous but i
know the people who are
and they get up every day on the front
lines grassroots communities
they don't have much but they're good
people and they fight hard
they don't have enough support can you
imagine
grassroots folks from appalachia from
the hood native american reservations
having enough money to be able to
connect with
the geniuses that have disrupted the
space industry
disrupted uh taxis and hotels and
bookstores
to start disrupting poverty to start
disrupting pollution
to start disrupting the 90 billion
dollar prison industry together
you take people on the front lines and
their
wisdom and their genius and their
creativity and you give them a
shot they're not just going to turn
around neighborhoods they're going to
turn around this nation
that's what's going to happen and i
appreciate you
for lifting the sealing off of people's
dreams
you have lifted the feelings off of the
dreams of humanity today
and that's an important thing don't be
mad about it when you see somebody
reaching for the heavens
be glad there's a lot more heaven up
there to reach for
and we can do that together and the last
thing i'll say is this
if this small group of people can make
miracles happen in outer space
a bigger group of people can make
miracles happen down here and we're
going to do it thank you very
much
hey guys can you roll a little video we
put together
about van jones can you roll that little
video please short video
van has been a part of much change he
has birthed a number of different
grassroots community organizations
he also helped us bring together climate
justice and racial justice
and what that meant in particular for
low-income communities of color you
can't live in a country
where you just have sacrifice zones
whether we're talking about south
central
or appalachia or the rust belt and no
political party stands up for him
effectively
he was always so ahead of the curve that
a lot of people didn't understand him
so that was always hard to watch because
i know
his love for people and for justice it
doesn't matter to him what people say he
continues to do the work that needs to
be done
i think about what he's done within the
criminal justice system
what he's done with making
bipartisanship real
not just what think tanks are doing not
researching the idea
not exploring in history how
bipartisanship worked he's been rolling
up his sleeves
he's been doing their work in real life
and i know that uh van jones is going to
uh do something amazing with that 100
million dollars i don't know what yet i
bet he doesn't know what yet
um but but it's in your hands van jones
however you're gonna do it
it's gonna work um we had lunch together
uh a couple weeks ago and
uh and he told me that he was just so
tell me some of his life story and he
mentioned that
when he was a young activist he was
angry
he had just like there's a big
transformation that happened over the
years he said
that his the acronym that he used was
rap
uh so for reward and punishment and if
the mayor or whoever it was that they
were
going up against did something they
liked they rewarded them if they did
something they didn't like they punished
them
and you said honestly jeff i wasn't very
good at the reward part
um i really focused on the punishment
part
and then he changed i mean he really the
transformation when you hear his story
is unbelievable
and profound and inspiring
and you can always and i think about
this for myself
you wake up every night when you go to
sleep you get the chance
to wake up better tomorrow
now we have
another awardee let's roll that video
jose andres calls himself a pilgrim from
spain
a chef who arrived here 20 years ago was
just 50 bucks in his pocket
but these days it's hard to call him
anything less than an amazing american
success story
i know you his love of his fellow men
and women his love of eating which he
shares with all of us he is bigger than
life
a force of nature and a real gift
michelin star
chef who has won james beard awards for
both outstanding chef
and humanitarian of the year jose andres
is turning several of his dc and new
york city restaurants
into community kitchen he has helped
feed those in disaster areas in the u.s
and around the world